now the idea of a strict personal moral
code based on an unchanging set of
universal rules is seen by many as
old-fashioned and victorian
yet most of us retain the desire to be a
good person and morality is often cited
to support political and cultural
opinions and actions
so is this a hypocrisy designed to make
us look good but avoiding having to
change our own behavior
if we're to make use of the notion of
morality must we see morality as a
universal set of rules or law that
applies to all in all circumstances
or can we endorse a personal morality
that's sustained by the consistency and
integrity of the individual to give it
force and value
well fascinating topic and we've got
three really interesting speakers here
to debate it first of all jesse norman
is a treasury minister but he's here
because he's a keen political
philosopher and author of compassionate
conservatism as well as biographies of
adam smith and edmund burke
julie bindle is a radical feminist
writer and co-founder of the law reform
group justice for women which helps
women who've been prosecuted for killing
violent male partners
and jonathan wolfe who's known as joe is
a moral philosopher at oxford university
he's developing a research program on
revitalizing democracy and civil society
and his work largely concerns equality
social justice and poverty
so as usual i'm going to ask each of the
three to do a three-minute pitch on the
question of is it hypocritical to
believe that other cultures have
different moralities and yet think that
we can be objectively good jesse norman
first
i think from a purely philosophical
perspective uh the answer to your
question is that there isn't anything
hypocritical about
uh believing in universal morality as
regards one's own self
which of course may be a belief that's
uh
deluded in its own right and yet
thinking that uh other other moralities
are in some sense non-universal or
partial and the reason for that is that
people can be radically solidistic they
can
just believe that they're right
um and that their world is the one that
as it were is the only true world and
we've seen examples in history
uh the spanish inquisition comes to mind
in which people might have taken the
view that other people could have uh
local morality to their own kind but
there was only one morality that really
mattered so uh that's i suppose the
overall question but there's a there's a
deeper in a way more interesting issue
for me which is you know whether
there are such things as or there could
be such a thing as a universal a single
universal morality and uh it it's
sometimes uh easy to think that that
might be so because there's so much
moralizing and denunciation that seems
to go on at the moment on social media
and elsewhere and some of that is
directed uh
as it were
encouraging people to do the right thing
from all the best motives but quite a
lot of it seems to me about uh to be
about virtue signaling or advertising
one's own prowess and uh of course
anyone watching this might think that uh
you know politicians of all kinds are
amongst the worst uh uh offenders in
this area
so uh what is it that we think about
when you think what a reversal morality
well i would say that it's something
which is um
actually very hard to imagine uh not
only not existing
in this world uh and anyone who thinks
differently might want to think about
the limitations of the best candidates
for that cantianism or utilitarianism
uh a philosophy of duties or a
philosophy of uh as it were the best
advantage based on the the best outcome
for the for the greatest number or some
such a hedonic calculus
and so looking at the failure of those
uh and insufficiency of those uh
philosophies those moralities points to
i think a wider idea which is that
actually we all seem to occupy some
world that tries to have a local
consistency but draws in on different
traditions and different ideas when we
have to make concrete judgments and that
i think actually is not only uh the
natural human tendency it's also
probably the uh philosophically speaking
the the the the best description we can
give of how people behave in outline
although we can always go deeper so the
final thought would be does that mean
that our personal moralities are
unimprovable absolutely not we can
always be
thinking about our own practice thinking
about
the rules and norms of our society
thinking about the best public policy
from a moral perspective that is more
demanding perhaps than
we're used to in order to test it in
order to see how good it is and we can
apply the same standards to our own
lives and try to live better lives
ourselves at the same time as well
thank you okay julie bendel
well i'm interested in the type of
cultural relativism
as a feminist who campaigns to end male
violence against women and girls
where
if we're in the west or the global north
looking out at
cultures for example in the global south
where there's lots of
discussion about whether it's judgmental
to condemn female genital mutilation
forced or early marriage
and the like
and yet the only
culture that's relevant in this
discussion as far as i'm concerned is
patriarchy so the culture of patriarchy
that excuses
or even condones and encourages the
abuse of women by men in order to uphold
that that power
but
conversely when morality is discussed
within the parameters
of sex and obviously as a feminist i'm
very very
interested in how male sexual behavior
um
upholds the systems of patriarchy when
morality is discussed often it's
actually in order to condemn the likes
of me
we are those of us that that speak out
against rape um against harmful sexual
practices that are now sold as
liberating such as choking spitting
during sex other forms of abusive
practice such as coercing women to watch
violent pornography and re-enact scenes
in violent pornography were actually
seen or labeled as
moralists and what that means is
anti-sex
puritan
it's very directly an insult which then
stifles a discussion about what a true
moral compass would be
what morality truly is when we look at
sex and sexual practice for example
prostitution the act of a man because it
usually almost always is a man
paying for access to the inside of a
woman's body because it almost always is
a woman for one-sided sexual pleasure
um we're told that we are moralistic if
we campaign to end the sex trade and
wish to imagine a world without
prostitution and yet is it really moral
to speak about consent when the cash is
the consent when it's clear to that man
paying for sex that the woman does not
want sex with him or he wouldn't be
paying her
so interesting sorry to interrupt but
isn't it interesting that the word
moralistic is actually applied
as a criticism as it's a derogatory word
whereas it ought to mean being moral
absolutely and is it really moral i mean
you've hit the nail on the head marianne
is it really moral to
think to dehumanize and commodify women
to the point of where you can separate
orifices um to which you you know you
pay for access
when it's clear that this is a one-sided
um arrangement
similarly you know when we when we speak
about sexual morality well people then
will think
we'll go back to
for example um victorian morality which
is supposedly anti-sex but during that
time during for example between 1880 and
1914 where feminists were speaking about
men's sexual behavior that's harmful to
women those feminists campaigned against
the abuse and exploitation
of poor women and girls within the sex
trade and also campaigned to end rape in
marriage to to criminalize rape and
marriage so to me um
as opposed to to wrap up
morality
when we think about it in terms of
feminism and about the kind of campaigns
that feminists that aim to end male
violence
uh
are involved in morality has to be about
reshaping
men's sexual rights and looking
at the way that those rights become
wrongs when done to women
we have to be able to imagine a world
without prostitution without rape
without male violence
um as a moral ethical and political goal
and a utopian goal because utopia is
underrated um and there's nothing of
course that is uh moral in abusing women
okay thank you joe wolfe
let me start trying to answer this
question by
telling you a little bit
about my teacher g.a cohen um so he was
a marxist much of his life he was
brought up in fact in a jewish
marxist household in montreal
and he was aware very aware that most of
his beliefs he got from his mother
and his local community and he said that
had he been brought up
in a different family if he had been
brought up in a conservative catholic
family he probably would have had quite
different beliefs
so thank goodness he said i was brought
up in the right family
now in his case
he thought he had the correct moral
views
even though he got them from his family
and thought that if he'd been brought up
in a different family he had different
views the wrong ones
so
philosophically i find this such an
interesting
story because
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai dot tv
for more debates and talks from the
world's leading thinkers on today's
biggest ideas
you